hi teachers sal khan here from khan
academy and i just wanted to remind you
that learnstorm is back and better than
ever and in case you're wondering why
should i use learnstorm or the learn
storm tracker we just have to remember
what it's like to be a learner a lot of
times as a learner you're trying to get
through the material it's just you and
the material it can feel a little bit
lonely but we know it's very motivating
to be part of something bigger than
yourself and so what learnstorm does is
it takes those individual learning
journeys of all your students as they're
trying to do their assignments on khan
academy as they're trying to get mastery
on khan academy and turns it into a
quest an adventure for the entire
classroom where you're all one team and
you as a teacher are their leader to see
if on a regular basis on a weekly basis
they can reach their goals
so use that learnstorm tracker to create
a sense of
excitement a sense of adventure a sense
of camaraderie and shared journey the
second reason and there are many others
to get very excited is that this year
finally learnstorm is not just measuring
whether students are doing assignments
but whether they're actually mastering
the content so this reinforces a growth
mindset if you haven't mastered it
that's okay you can have another shot
you just haven't mastered it yet so
we're so excited to be partnering with
all of you and all of your students on
this year's learnstorm adventure